[Music]
black widow is unafraid
and she is tangled that was not part of
the plan
how many people are supposed to eat this
because just me right now
avengers campus is an entirely new six
acre land here at disney california
adventure it's dedicated to finding
recruiting and training the next
generation of heroes
i am moving in here shine me up
the first stop for any superhero web
suppliers
[Music]
oh sorry okay
here at webb suppliers this is where the
worldwide engineering brigade
is showcasing some of its latest
technology
and inventions so that our recruits can
gear up and practice for their next
mission at avengers campus and beyond
spiderbots and here at web suppliers
you can leave with your own spiderbot
the story here
spiderman peter parker invented
spiderbots and they're out of control
and now
are you ready to battle kind of okay
oh no wait go black widow is not afraid
oh and she is tangled um
go go go
put me in the avengers
[Music]
we've gotten our supplies we've learned
to battle the bots now
it's time to get on the web slingers
ride and save
avengers campus do i sound like a
superhero
i'm working on it i like this one
[Music]
web slingers of spider-man adventure is
a brand new attraction here at avengers
campus where guests are actually going
to go along with spider-man and get to
sling webs while on a mission
once we head inside we actually get to
meet peter parker and he's going to
demonstrate some of these really cool
technologies
but when things get out of hand his
buddy spider-man shows up and invites
us to help him on a mission to save
avengers campus
spider-man is going to be seen in a lot
of ways you're going to see him jump
across the top of that building
you're also going to see him fly 85 feet
near
you're going to get to train along with
the dora melange and for the first time
in any disney park
general okoye is going to join them and
courage are like
the sun they have to rise out of us
we're going to learn the ways of wakanda
and the ways to being a warrior ally
also the whole area is filled with
really interesting mysterious things
that you're going to want to explore
after saving avengers campus everybody's
a little tired could use a snack so
just like the avengers let's have some
shawarma
you ever tried shwarma there's a
shawarma joint about two blocks from
here
i don't know what it is but i want to
try it the avengers were so impressed by
the chicken shawarma
they had to have it down here on the
avengers campus every superhero needs a
snack
let's power up and i got one of
pretty much everything that's delicious
this candy bar got enlarged in ant-man
and the wasps pym
test kitchen and i'm not complaining
pim test kitchen is based on the movie
ant-man and the wasp where you can see
that pin particles can shrink
just about anything and grow just about
anything exciting
wow i don't know what food group this is
but
i'm in food innovation meets science
here pim test kitchen
hulk smash
i think it's gratuitous but whatever
like the avengers teams of extraordinary
imagineers have come together to create
something larger than themselves
it's been really exciting to collaborate
with our partners at the studio
that have been bringing these
extraordinary characters to life on
screen
and now we get to walk amongst them one
more one more so for the first time the
heroes are going to assemble
an avengers campus and you're going to
be a part of it we want you to join the
fun
saved the avengers campus tried the
chicken shawarma i'm basically an
avenger
[Music]
right